Spinosaurus is probably the most
enigmatic dinosaur out there for decades
paleontologists have disagreed on how
Spinosaurus and Jim takus a huge
Cretaceous predator might have lived and
hunted now a new skeleton discovered in
Morocco has revealed an unexpected
surprise in the tail of this enormous
hunter we're digging up bones you can
imagine I've never seen anything like
this before the new bones suggest that
Spinosaurus swam through the water
propelled by a powerful tail a lifestyle
apparently unique among dinosaurs we can
finally flesh out this bizarre
mysterious dinosaur and it turns out it
was even stranger than we expected
so what you see here is the Sahara one
of the driest places on earth but a
hundred million years ago this was a
huge river system Nyssa Ibrahim wanted
to be a paleontologist since he was five
so a trip to the Sahara to uncover a new
Spinosaurus skeleton was a dream come
true
especially given the scarcity of
Spinosaurus bones we're finding bone
after bone after bone and I couldn't
believe it it was like being a
five-year-old all over again
the only other Spinosaurus skeleton that
had ever been found was destroyed in
World War two and so we had this
tantalizing clues we knew the
Spinosaurus looked really strange it had
a giant sail on its back and narrow jaws
like a crocodile and we knew it was very
big probably even bigger than t-rex but
there was about it we really didn't know
anything about the lifestyle of
Spinosaurus and it's detailed Anatomy a
particular mystery was the tale of a
Spinosaurus a part of his body only
known from a few fragmentary bones
previous reconstructions showed a long
thin tail similar to other theropod
dinosaurs but when nazar and his team
started excavating the tail of the new
specimen they knew they'd found
something special so we're excavating
caudal vertebrae the tail vertebrae and
there's a spine at the top writes the
neural spine we still haven't reached
the end no it's not that's really weird
this is a tail bone at the end of the
tail why on earth does it have such a
long spine yeah 52 centimeters almost 53
actually no other dinosaur has tail
bones like this and that's when we
realized that the tail was basically
like a giant fin Nizar suspected that
this fin would have made Spinosaurus an
adept swimmer
to test the idea he sent the
reconstructed shape to colleagues at
Harvard University where they crafted
plastic tails representing Spinosaurus
to other theropod dinosaurs a crocodile
underneath
they then measured the thrust and
efficiency of each tail shape as it
moved in the water the spinosaurus tail
really outperforms the other dinosaur
tails and it is comparable in many ways
with the tails of crocodiles and newts
so what the experiments showed was that
this was a clear advantage for an animal
pursuing prey in the water spinosaurus
aquatic lifestyle has been the subject
of decades of debate while there were
several other large aquatic reptiles in
this period
none were dinosaurs for a very very long
time
paleontologists assume the one thing
dinosaurs never did was invade the
watery world aquatic ecosystems there
were already several pieces of evidence
pointing towards Spinosaurus being
adapted for water crocodile like teeth
for grasping fish dense bones for
buoyancy control and short hind legs
unsuited to running still researchers
disagreed on just how reliant
Spinosaurus was on aquatic prey and
whether it swam or just waded in the
shallows Nyssa believes this new find
could settle the debate the big thing we
were missing was a propulsive structure
because you can't really be an aquatic
predator unless you have some way to
catch prey in the water and move through
the water and so that's what we now
found we now know that this dinosaur had
a thin like tail that propelled it
through this river system so this was a
River monster it was a dinosaur that did
things that no other dinosaur did
paleontologists knew that dinosaurs went
on to conquer the skies but this is the
strongest evidence yet that at least one
of them also conquered the waters
it could be that the spinosaurus is
unique or it could show just how much
there is left to learn about the age of
dinosaurs
[Music]